on peut se demander si les efforts fait
par les agriculteurs depuis les 20
dernières années ont permis d'améliorer
la qualité de nos cours d'eau en fait
selon un récent rapport du ministère de
l'Environnement et de la lutte contre
les changements climatiques la réponse
courte c'est non selon ce rapport le
moratoire peut-être stabilisé la qualité
de l'eau mais il n'a pas mené à une
amélioration notable en voici quelques
détails selon le rapport qui date de
2020 l'état global des 22 cours d'eau
situés dans des bassins versants
agricoles qui font l'objet de suivi et
jugé mauvais une situation qui perdure
depuis 2010 la forte concentration
d'élevage dans certains bassins versants
contribuent de façon importante à la
contamination il y a trop de phosphore
dans l'eau un nutriment très présent
dans le fumier et pendu sur les grandes
cultures de maïs et de soya
la présence de pesticides dans les cours
d'eau en milieu agricole est aussi
inquiétante la majorité des 46 rivières
qui font l'objet de suivi sont en
mauvais état plusieurs dépassant les
critères de qualité de l'eau établies
pour la protection des espèces
aquatiques
enfin 59 petits cours d'eau en milieu
agricole sont aussi jugés en mauvais
état quand on considère la présence de
diatomées bintiques de petites algues
très sensibles aux pollutions organiques
et aux nutriments comme le phosphore et
l'azote la situation ne s'est pas
améliorée depuis 2010 mais il y a une
note encourageante la majorité des
stations contrôlées pour la
concentration d'azote ammoniacale une
forme d'azote toxique pour la vie
aquatique a connu une tendance
significative à la baisse entre 2002 et
2017 ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que ça
peut être long une fois qu'on adopte une
nouvelle pratique avant d'en voir les
résultats par exemple depuis 2018 il
faut une prescription agronomique pour
utiliser des néonicotinoïdes l'usage de
ces insecticides a donc chuté de manière
significative pourtant on les détecte
encore dans les rivières à des seuils
nuisibles pour les organismes aquatiques
il ne faut donc pas tarder à agir quand
il s'agit de protéger nos écosystèmes